[Music]
thank you
welcome to wisdom for life where we sift
through philosophy to find practical
advice that you can use in your everyday
life hi I'm Dan Hayes I'm joined by my
co-host Dr Greg Sadler and today we're
talking about the adjunctification of
higher education and if you heard that
that word what the hell is that so it
comes from the word adjunct and we're
going to tell you what an adjunct is in
just a minute we don't mean like
adjuncts that you you know put into food
products or things like that we're
talking about higher education and this
may come as a big surprise to people who
aren't in the business or the racket as
we might call it of higher education
just how many adjuncts are out there and
you know we thought before we get into
all the stats and definitions that we
should
get into or at least put on the table
why why should anyone care about this so
Dan you gave some thought to that what
are what are your views
um yeah so like
I see there's definitely like two major
constituencies here you have the actual
um students
um and then the the
population at large they're going to
have different you know ideas and this
should be closer further and So like um
definitely if there's as we'll see
there's not a lot of money that's going
to these adjuncts who are teaching a
large percentage of these courses and so
if there's they're not getting paid very
well and where's all the money for the
coursework actually going right
and um you know there's also this worry
about like what about the the quality of
the um actual instruction but well we're
going to talk about that in a minute
there's
so there's good news and bad news and
we'll tell you what that isn't just a
bit
uh and then there's like definitely you
know the man on the street you're
thinking about
um you know how we actually uh try to
order our society you know that their
labor is sold for uh you know salary or
whatever uh income that they're in so
um but you rather wouldn't have people
be exploited for your late their labor
and um you know if you're a teacher then
you should be spending the most amount
of your time either teaching or kind of
like prepping and doing the things that
you need for teaching and not doing some
you know side gig to play it for the
bills and the last thing is that I was
really hoping that you're going to like
do little Beastie Boys with this uh
Title Here the objectification of higher
education oh you want me to rap ah just
one bar yeah I mean I don't think I have
the meter for it you know
I mean if we want to joke around the
meters running and we got to get to all
the other stuff
um I don't know maybe maybe I'll come up
with some good lines later on but but I
I think going back to like the man on
the street or the you know the
proverbial Joe or Josephine blow uh as
as we often say we can say well why
should they care about what's happening
in higher education if they've like gone
to college great they're done with it or
if they didn't go to college and they
managed to get work anyway you know why
be concerned and and I think one you
know answer to that that you touched on
already is while we live in a society
and you know a lot of the jobs that
people are going to be doing they do
have to get educated and so we should
care about how Educational Systems
whereas we're going to talk about
non-systems
fragmentary systems actually work here
in this country and it's a big political
issue too I mean if people have been
paying any attention they know that in a
lot of red States there's movements to
kind of Choke off higher ed in different
ways and you know adjunctification isn't
necessarily at the heart of that but
some of the things that are side topics
like academic freedom fit in there and
you know we we need an educated
Workforce in a in order to have a
well-functioning society so everybody
not everybody does care about this issue
but everybody really ought to care at
least a little bit about this issue
yeah it's not you know a lot of places
in this country that you can you know go
down to the plant
um right out of high school and just
pick up a job that's going to be able to
pay you in order to you know raise a
family anymore that they're that's right
yeah we live in a very
highly educated Workforce because the
you know jobs that are now available are
mostly knowledge jobs or service jobs
and these things require usually a
larger amount of Education you know and
I'll say something to uh about trade
unions there's a lot of different kinds
of unions but the ones where you've got
skilled workers
um I want to you know and I'll actually
tell you a story I've got an uncle who's
just retired from being an iron worker
and he was a drywaller from the time he
was 16 years old until about I want to
say about 40 years old and then you know
we had that that terrible market crash
in 2007 and 2008 all across the economy
and his boss decided to no longer
provide them with health insurance and
he had a family to support so he he quit
and then he his son was in the iron
workers this is down in Indiana and he
joined the iron workers and the first
thing that they did in his
apprenticeship was send him to two years
of college
where you had to study you know not only
mathematics and and you know you did
some Hands-On welding stuff and you had
to learn how to write how to communicate
in in writing effectively because that's
very important but you also had to study
labor history and they actually it's
part of your apprenticeship they paid
for that degree he was scared because he
had been I mean so that would have been
at least 20 years since he'd graduated
from high school he had no intention of
ever going to college and uh he was
really worried about that and I told him
hey you're going to be fine you got a
good work ethic you know you haven't
forgotten everything that you learned
back then you're actually a smart guy
you just don't have a degree and I don't
know if you believe me or not but he he
got all straight A's and you know after
his first semester I was like yeah I'm
proud of you Uncle Scott uh look at you
did it you know but notice even for a
blue-collar job some college
is required in a situation like that a
lot of times you can't get a blue collar
job without some sort of academic
training you know it might be at the
community college it might be a
four-year degree
so even the idea like you said I'm just
going to go down to the mill with my
lunchbox and my overalls and I'll get a
job down no that's that's not the way it
works anymore you know
so we should uh oh go ahead oh I was
just saying and even if you're talking
about the newer manufacturing jobs newer
manufacturing jobs are it's not like you
uh getting an impact wrench and you know
repeatedly going at uh you know adding a
new wheel to a car yeah
um
yeah yeah most of that stuff is now done
by robots if anything that can be
repeatable has been done to a point that
it's going to remove as much labor and
so the whole point is uh they need you
to be able to run complex machines and
you're not going to get that without a
little bit of extra work
yeah so uh coming back to the adjunct
thing yeah we said what are we gonna
what is an adjunct we'll we'll tell you
about that so it's somebody who is hired
to teach classes in a higher education
institution so we're talking about
colleges universities other things like
that and what makes them an adjunct is
that they're not on what we call the
tenure track and a lot of people are
really mixed up about this and the media
doesn't help with this because they they
keep showing College professors in TV
shows and movies are all basically old
school tenure track professors tenure is
something that you get after generally
putting in six to seven years and it
gives you like a lifetime security right
you don't have to be rehired over and
over again you're in so if you're not on
the tenure track you never have that
protection and in addition to that as an
adjunct you're ineligible for any real
promotion as a matter of fact you're not
getting what a full-timer who's not on
the tender track would would get as far
as pay or benefits and you're hired each
semester or if you're lucky each year
per term and per class to teach so
you're really like a Hired Gun you're
brought in and you might do that for 20
years at an institution but you never
have any job security
so the the other thing that makes it a
little tricky is if you look at
different schools they use different
language for this some of them will call
you an adjunct at one of the places I
teach I'm actually an adjunct full
Professor
um which is kind of cool because they
have like different ranks you know but
um you're not really a full Professor
you're an adjunct and you might also be
called a lecturer or instructor or
part-time faculty
and one now here's where it gets tricky
right you could say oh well that's fine
because we have a meritocracy you know
you start out at the bottom just like
any other business and you work your way
up well it's not quite like that in
Academia adjuncts are usually as
qualified as the tenure track professors
they're just not getting the same Rank
and the same benefits and the same
security and the same pay as them
sometimes you can have places where the
full-time professors are less qualified
than the adjuncts
um and they're also distinct from other
teachers who aren't on the tenure track
so you could be what's called a teaching
professor at Marquette some of my
colleagues are this and they teach four
classes per semester but they are not
eligible for tenure or promotion they
they it's better than being an adjunct
in some ways but you're also still not
getting your share of the pie and now
why do we care about this I mean you can
say well you know people know what
they're getting into so this goes to
something that Dan brought up at the
very beginning
adjuncts over the last 20 years have
become a really large proportion of the
people who are doing the teaching in
most academic institutions
the proportion of them is large already
and it's continually growing so odds are
if you're taking a college level class
and it's not being taught by some
graduate assistant there's a good chance
you're actually being taught by an
adjunct and you might not know it
because they don't often tell you that
and in some schools you're actually
discouraged from revealing your adjunct
status there are some places here in the
greater Milwaukee area where they there
may be only one full-time person in the
department one person who has tenure and
everybody else's adjuncts
so
let me play devil's advocate here yeah
why should we care like why why should
these professors have you know extra
protections that
um I'll allow them
um you know that they don't want to
constantly be renewing their contract to
everyone else is is constantly you know
on the knife's edge that they can be
fired at any point in time what what is
the point of this you know Extra
Protection yeah it's it's sort of like
saying well Wisconsin in general is an
at-will state right
I mean it's not completely because if
you have a union job then you're not
just at will right
um
but when we talk about just about
Academia
um you do want to have continuity right
you don't want to be necessarily
restarting a department every semester
and
um traditionally 10 years been a way to
do that it also provides what we call
academic freedom and this is one of
those big blurry terms that can mean a
lot of different things to different
people but it basically boils down to
you get to teach in your classroom what
you see fit to teach as a professional
who has been educated in that field and
knows better than the students probably
the administrators or other stakeholders
who might want to come in
now sometimes that that's not actually
the reality right I mean there are
plenty of professors teaching various
things who let their their skills their
knowledge base kind of go to seed maybe
they're not teaching The Cutting Edge
best you know practices stuff but at
least in theory academic freedom is
supposed to be uh what tenure it
provides but I think part of it is also
that that issue of continuity and then
we can also talk about you know people
getting what they're paying for you
brought up a great point if the school
has been saving money for years and
years and years by hiring adjuncts where
did all that money go and that's a a
valid question and just to put it in
perspective so I've taught as an adjunct
I was just looking at my my teaching
career I've taught in 11 different
places over the last 22 years in one of
those a graduate instructor okay so we
put that aside because that's just you
know what you do as a graduate student
and then one of them I was tenure track
and I was actually up for early tenure
in promotion one I taught for six years
as non-tenure track and that's because I
was teaching in the prison in the
extended education program but that was
full time it had benefits all that nice
stuff
and then the other eight have been as
adjuncts
and when you look at what a college
course costs at a lot of these places
I I tell my students this when I go in
if we have a class of 30 students one of
them is paying for my services actually
sometimes one of them is paying for my
services and then some other stuff on
top of that the other 29 that money is
not going to the professor even if you
have a full-time Professor who is
tenured at best five of those 30
students are paying for that Professor
so where's all the other money going to
well you know it's administrators and
buildings and maybe going into the
endowment and uh you know paying staff
and building new things and there's all
sorts of initiatives that it might be
going into but the professors are not
where the great costs of Education lie
today
so I want to go back to um something
that you said just a moment ago about
academic freedom yeah why
should the teachers professors
um choose what they want to teach and
not the the administrators not the
administrators the one they're supposed
to set the well administrators usually
don't know anything I mean this is one
of the dirty little secrets of Academia
um there's basically two kinds of
Administrators there's the ones who've
like risen through the ranks
and so you know you become a department
chair and then maybe you move on and
become an assistant Dean and a dean and
you can move up that way right and then
you could act at least plausibly say
that you know something about your
subject but let's say we take philosophy
right so you have to specialize in
something and there's no way that any
one person no matter how smart they are
actually knows like the whole field of
philosophy
so you know if you specialized in
Aristotle and you do great work on that
you may not have any idea how I should
be teaching Renee Descartes or Mary
woolstonecraft or any of that sort of
stuff so you gotta you actually have to
respect the expertise and this is you
know hopefully they have expertise of
the professors but then you also have
these professional administrators that
at best have a degree in like
educational leadership and there are
Mills that are just churning these
people out you know and the Dirty Little
Secret of educational leadership is that
they don't really learn a lot
they learn some management techniques
they learn some education jargon they
learn a few things about assessment of
student learning and that's about it
they are not qualified to go into a
classroom that many of them have never
actually been in and say this person is
teaching well or this person is teaching
poorly and and you know they should be
teaching Nietzsche better or or anything
like that so so academic freedom in part
I mean I never thought of it this way it
keeps the administrators from screwing
things up more than they already do
screw things up
that's a very cynical answer but yeah
yeah I guess one one extra layer here
but for public institutions yeah
um but uh what if it's a state is
putting so much money into the uh higher
education don't they have some say over
what you as professors should be
teaching well they do and the say is
that you should be teaching what you got
hired to teach
you know so if you're hired to teach
sociology classes you know your peers
will evaluate whether you're doing it
well I mean the average person on the
street can't walk in and evaluate that
any more than they can tell a master
electrician what to do you know they're
not they're not a skilled worker in that
respect I mean and this is where we run
it is very funny because certain
disciplines like people say oh I'm a
political junkie or I'm a history buff
you might be but that doesn't mean that
you actually know as much as somebody
who's actually studied history and
written a dissertation where they did
historical research or done you know
political science work quantitatively
crunching the numbers after doing
polling or something like that right
accept this in certain areas and then in
other areas you know we're a little bit
more respectful of experts
expertise their their knowledge base
that they've built up I mean you know
you wouldn't say I've watched some uh
um popular things about physics I think
I could go in and evaluate what the
physics department is doing
I I watched a Gray's Anatomy I can
totally like go in oversee properly the
medical Department yeah actually I mean
this is a whole different topic right
but we we could actually do a whole show
on like
mistaken conceptions of
professional practices that come to us
from TV shows I mean watching watching
Law and Order does not tell you how to
do policing well or courtroom stuff well
you know right I feel like it's a
special version of the dunning-kruger
effect
explain that because I think maybe some
of our our listeners don't know what
you're referencing so Dunning Krueger
are to uh psychology professors who
um were doing a number of experiments in
which one
got coined the dunning-kruger effect
which is that um the people that are
worse at a thing often are the ones that
perceive their ability of that thing to
be
um the best and so the more the more you
know about the things the less uh
confident you are that you know the
thing well because it's like oh you know
you go into like think of whatever uh
specialty that you get into so for
example you know computer science and
you get in there it's like okay
um I feel good about like you know my
first couple of courses and then you get
like a year or two and it's like oh my
gosh there's like this giant world is
now opening up and you realize how
little that you you know right now and
you're like well I'm not going to be
able to investigate 80 of this hell
maybe even like 95 of this I'm going to
have to really specialize if I want to
be at the very bleeding edge of
something and
this whole idea is that you know you're
you're really bad at on
self-assessing your ability yeah
and it's actually worse for people that
are really good in another field so
doctors have a really bad dunning-kruger
effect for other disciplines that they
don't know about in part because they
have this perception this correct
perception that they are an expert in
something and thus that transfers
somehow to something else now this is a
problem as old as ancient Greece
Socrates in the apology when he's like
defending himself pretty poorly uh it
looks like he's kind of throwing the
trial in in Plato's apology uh talks
about the old
um adversaries or the old critics that
that he's got and what he means by this
are people that he's ticked off in the
past by showing that they don't they
don't actually know what they're talking
about so he went to the politicians the
people who are running things and he
asked some questions and turns out they
just kind of you know go by by hunches
and the seat of their pants they don't
actually know what they're doing and it
goes to the artists The Poets and turns
out they can't actually explain their
own poetic Productions and by this we
mean cultural Productions like what
would be the equivalent of TV shows and
movies now ancient plays then it goes to
the crafts people and he says they
actually know something they know their
their area and one example of
craftspeople from that time are doctors
and it's exactly as you say they think
that because they know something over
here and they know it well they can
produce reliable effects and they can
teach it to people they can do the same
with some other totally unrelated area
of expertise and they probably treat it
you know like a plumber looks at
everything like it's pipes a doctor
looks at everything like the medical
problem you know I suppose a firework
maker would look at everything like it's
a firework display
um I don't know exactly what that would
translate into we'd have to think that
through but this is so this is a
long-standing problem and coming back to
the adjunct thing right and academic
freedom you don't want people who are
unqualified making decisions about what
gets taught in the classroom
I I said we had good news bad news about
that
um so you know
the bad news is that a lot of the people
who should know what they're doing in
the classroom don't know what they're
doing
so it's uh you know and it can be a lot
of people on the tenure track or tenured
who just aren't very good at pedagogy
they're not good at teaching right they
may be great researchers they may be
great grant writers but they just can't
teach to save their life but some of
them actually don't know much about
their topics either you know you can you
can find that they have got things wrong
so you know let's actually jump to this
this mistaken concern about the quality
of instruction and I think the argument
kind of makes sense until you start
looking into it and if you haven't like
opened up the can of worms that is
Academia and the basic argument is that
um
because the adjuncts are not getting
good pay and they're not getting any
professional development we'll talk
about what that means in a bit and
because they have to work a lot of hours
students are not going to get the same
high quality of instruction from
adjuncts as they would be from tenure
track faculty right so you you've got
like two different classes of teachers
and it you know it kind of makes sense
because if you think about like let's
say you want to get your hair cut
um do you go to somebody who owns their
own shop and has been cutting hair there
and built up a clientele for a decade or
do you want to go to somebody who
rotates from shop to shop to shop and
just takes whatever work they can get
you're probably going to get a better
haircut from the first person right
so you know there's it kind of makes
sense it's a plausible argument
and there's this interesting uh
reference to a Delphi project in this
this in this piece that was published
just last year by Alexander bradner the
cruelty of the adjunct system where she
wrote Scholars of student learning and
higher ed from the research-based Delphi
project have found that the over
Reliance on adjuncts has at least eight
negative effects on student learning
effects that stem largely from reduced
contact time and lack of energy for high
impact teaching practices
now that's interesting but the reality
is that most instructors are not using
what we call high impact teaching
practices that's it's only a minority
who are doing that right and you don't
have to be
taught any pedagogy in order to actually
be a professor or an adjunct you just
need to know your topic I've had so many
professors they're
probably brilliant I couldn't tell you
if they were because of the way that
they were trying to convey this
information yeah I feel like
anytime they become a professor adjunct
or not you should be like okay we're
gonna give you uh like continuing
education
um go or go do
a theater course or um be interesting
yeah yeah you know because like part of
it is
um you are standing up there in your
performing
um either you have to make sure that
you're enunciating so that people can
hear you
um you have to command the stage you
need to know how to you know hold the
presence and the attention of all the
people that are there as well as you
know a lot of the different of
techniques that are uh you know I don't
know them because I've never gone to
teaching school but pedagogical of
techniques for actually making sure that
people understand the thing that you're
trying to do and if I had to go through
one more like you know slide show where
the professor is just reading off the
slides yeah in a monotone voice and
we're we're going to talk about page six
today and we'll you know you get the
point it it is
not the way that you want your higher
education to be you you should be there
going oh I get to do all the courses I
learn all the things and I'm so
incredibly excited for and you're stuck
with something that is below par yeah
and we're talking about this a little
bit earlier as a student
the whole system is opaque
the best that you can do is look at Rate
My Professor and hope that the people
who put in the reports weren't too
biased when they did so
um a lot of times you know we know that
the same problems with student
evaluations show up and Rate My
Professor it's very unscientific and
um and a lot of times you don't you know
you don't have any idea what the person
whose class you're taking is going to be
like until you're stuck with them and
you pay the same the same amount for a
good professor as you do for a terrible
professor as a student
so this is a big problem
um I I mean I will say this
um it is true that adjuncts over the
Long Haul are probably not getting to do
as much professional development meaning
to go to conferences to you know
um learn the newest theories or stuff
like that as tenure track professors are
this is one of the inequities of it but
the dirty little secret is that many of
the tenure track professors don't take
advantage of that and they just get into
their position and they keep teaching
the same stuff year after year after
year with little changes and very little
review of their pedagogy and no big
incentives to learn more about how to be
a better teacher
um so you know this is it is a real
point but it's one of those things where
good news is you're just as lik likely
to get a bad teacher who is tenured than
one who's an adjunct that's also the bad
news right yeah
so there's no current mechanism for
trying to either reform or to you know
weed out those that are yeah bad at that
now this leads to another thing that we
have to point out and this is an
epistemological problem so having to do
with knowledge right
there is no educational system in the
United States
and you might say well wait a second we
we have a Department of Education that's
fine but that doesn't have very much to
do at all with how things are different
from say just here in the Milwaukee area
UW Milwaukee to Marquette to mount Mary
to Concordia to msoe to my ad these are
all different entities and they all do
their different things and even in the
same
School the different departments are
doing different things one Department
could be great and the other department
could be terrible and everything in
between and there generally isn't an
awful lot of attention to making sure
that people are teaching well I mean we
make sure that they actually show up but
you know and we do look at student
evaluations which we know are from you
know the research that's out there are
not reliable for for much of anything
other than to tell somebody's really
really bad
but there's no consistency across the
board and I think that a lot of people
out there their minds get boggled by
this because of course there has to be a
system
and the reality is in other countries
there is there is a higher education
system there are consistent standards
across Germany there are consistent
standards across France right there
aren't even here in Milwaukee between
the institutions of higher education
that we have just in the city limits and
there aren't even for most of them in
the same school within that University
or college or even sometimes in the
department
so that's one of the again I mentioned
dirty little secrets that you learn from
being on the inside well that is one of
them so even with like a state system
like we've got UW you know Milwaukee I
mentioned and UW-Madison and then the
next largest is UW Oshkosh then we have
you know Green Bay and stout and white
water and all that
and actually take it back with white
water because white water is one of
those like tightly focused schools on
business right and uh Madison has a law
school right and
um you know Milwaukee has PEC School of
the Arts right and within particular
schools you might have consistency but
even in a state system you don't you
don't have consistency across the system
so this is a big problem
but but great you sure the the market
just so decide this and yeah
there is there is effectively no real
Market
because in order to have a Mark I mean
you could say this you don't have a
market with a capital M you have a
million little individual markets that
sometimes respond to each other
and
um the prices are very you know
unreliable as to Quality and you can't
actually look at the product until
you've bought it
so
I don't know is that is is that a market
that could decide
well it's it's a very opaque Market that
will not respond to
uh yeah so if you if you can't if you
can't have any information going into it
then you can't actually make a choice
yeah a proper choice I mean in a lot of
places you can't even know by looking at
the University website what the
proportion of adjuncts to tenure track
to full-time non-tenure track faculty is
sometimes the adjuncts aren't even on
the University website right I've taught
places where I'm essentially a ghost
and
um in other cases the adjuncts will be
treated almost as if they are full-time
faculty they'll have big web pages and
stuff like that and you have no idea
that what you're dealing with are a
whole bunch of adjuncts with one share
of a department I won't say which school
it is whose philosophy and a couple
other departments around here are like
that I'll just say that there is one
within the
greater Milwaukee area
which is like that
well uh
I
and I assume that you've got like mdas
and whatnot that prevent you know what
I'm talking about that no no I just
don't want to bad mouth anybody okay and
I don't want to give the impression that
just hiring adjuncts is necessarily bad
because we can't tell the quality of
Education in general so I don't want
people to you know look down on that
Institution for essentially farming out
almost all of the work to adjuncts I
will say this that school is made a
devil's bargain because that money
that's saved by
um you know hiring more and more
adjuncts that money just gets gets
essentially thrown away on whatever it
is the administrators decide to funnel
the money into and you never get that
money back so you know a lot of people
would say oh well why don't we just fix
things you know
um just let's uh take the adjuncts and
give them job security and raise their
their income and we'll talk about what
the actual income of adjuncts is in a
minute so you'll get an idea about why
this is such an issue
that money isn't available anymore
it's been essentially thrown away
River yeah imagine that you had a
business right and what they did is they
cut everybody's benefits and uh wages or
salary down to a third to a quarter of
what it was and then they just held a
bunch of parties
you're never getting that money back
right
so I mean how much how much are adjuncts
making let's let's talk as they say
turkey right
um
what's that I never figured that one out
I don't know what the origin of that is
either frankly
frankly or Franklin I know that he was
big on the turkey that's true yeah I
mean I could have could have something
to do with him so so adjuncts right
um this is where it gets again very
interesting as well so if you look out
there and you just Google adjunct uh
salaries or adjuncts wages you can find
a lot of incorrect information so I'll
tell you about some of that that I I
found just Googling
um and it's irresponsibly wrong right it
gives people totally incorrect ideas
about adjunct salaries so zippia says
the average adjunct professor salary in
Wisconsin is eighty six thousand dollars
the average Professor tenured salary in
Wisconsin is not eighty six thousand
dollars it's way lower than that you
know
um so they they then said that adjunct
professor salaries in Wisconsin range
between forty two thousand and a hundred
and seventy five thousand dollars a year
there's nobody who's making a hundred
as an adjunct and there's very few who
are making 42 as adjuncts uh indeed said
that the national average salary for an
Adjunct professor is one hundred and
twenty three thousand
most professors tenured are not making
remotely close to that so there's no way
adjuncts are getting anywhere near that
glass door is a little bit more
realistic saying that they make 119 000
a year I mean it sounds like good money
right but
um it's still La La Land adjuncts don't
get salaries to begin with so you know
that that information is wrong and if
they did these would be totally High
what do you get
if you're an adjunct you don't have any
benefits you don't get health insurance
you don't get retirement so we we don't
count any of that sort of money in there
it starts at about 1800 a class I
actually had somebody a friend of mine
offer me a class at 1800 recently now
that is for an entire semester that's
teaching three credits
eighteen hundred dollars a class that
that's really low it it can go lower
than that
some places pay pretty decently they
might pay eight thousand ten thousand
dollars you know University of Notre
Dame does Good by its adjuncts places on
the East Coast have to pay more because
things cost more
but the average is in the 2500 to 3 000
range
so imagine so this is for a year how
many classes would you need to teach in
order to make say 30 grand you need to
teach 10 classes now that's more than a
full-time load and that's if you can
find 10 classes so adjuncts are you know
we call it the gig economy they're it's
the same sort of thing as happening to
people who work for Uber or eat Street
you know they are not getting paid well
at all and this you know you're required
to meet with your classes hold office
hours all of that sort of stuff
sometimes unionization can raise adjunct
wages but that's if you're in a state
that is receptive to unions
you know
the uh um graduate students at Marquette
and adjuncts were trying to unionize
before covid hit it takes years to get a
union in place and then you have to do
the collective bargaining
so adjuncts are not making much money at
all and this is where you know a sort of
inequity sets in right
at the price you're basically on the
edge you're not living a good life
that's right you know uh you're you're
barely making more than just poverty
line
um and these are supposed to be
good jobs that are like trying to be you
know if you're you're parents these are
the people that you're you're
kids are uh being taught by or that that
these are your professors is that just
doesn't seem right
yeah I mean I I do want to say so there
are adjuncts who are in somewhat
different circumstances and I'm one of
them I have my own business right if I
had to make it just as an adjunct
um boy I'd just be eaten beans and rice
all the time because that's all I could
afford and I sure wouldn't be living
here in the downtown of Milwaukee I'd
have to live way the hell out in the
middle of nowhere because uh rent is
expensive and I I make more with my
business than I do teaching and so I'm
what you call a working professional
there's like lawyers who will teach a
class here and there in the law school
and you know people who are kind of
Moonlighting right and then there's
spousal hires you know your spouse has a
good job at the University and you get
hired to teach a class here and there
that's that's not too bad right
um sometimes there's uh people who have
other education related work like they
might be teaching in the center for
excellence in teaching and learning
and then they also teach a class on the
side or they're an administrator who
teaches and then you know grad students
who are teaching as adjuncts I did that
I worked at a community college while I
was um a graduate student to get some
teaching experience and you're a
graduate student so you're used to
having no money anyway it's not a big
deal right
but the bulk of adjuncts are people who
are trying to make a living teaching as
adjuncts at multiple institutions
and some people are teaching at four or
five different places every semester
and going from one to the other to the
other and you can only really do that in
places where there's lots of schools you
know so that's a miserable life
and that'll win you know yeah
thankfully you know I guess Milwaukee
has a number of institutions
um
like it really only works at least
partially if you have a high density you
know like Boston has incredible that's
right yeah New York is is another place
where many people will teach I mean my
my wife
um she's taught massive teaching loads
as an adjunct in the past
um going from one institution to the
next to the next and you know basically
just that's all she did
so
yeah so there's a lot of people
um trying to make it and it's um
like you said it's not really a life
it's not a good life no but it's it's
sold as and so here's where we get into
some of the um
the other problems with being an adjunct
and these are ethical problems right
so one of the ways that I've seen a lot
of people and I've I've actually fallen
into this myself get suckered is they
hire you as an adjunct and they're like
you know if a full-time position ever
comes open in the department you are
going to be a shoe-in and so many of my
fellow graduates
I saw this happen they could teach at an
institution full-time position comes
open they don't even get considered for
it because if you're an adjunct there's
this presumption that well you you
couldn't cut it you weren't as good
why would we hire you to bring you in to
do things and so this is
um this is something that's really
demoralizing and and I found this
interesting discussion in this book the
adjunct underclass by herb Childress
calling adjunct labor hope labor and
hope labor is on or under compensated
War carried out in the present often for
experience or exposure in the hope that
future employment opportunities may
follow and then you know for many
adjuncts that hope comes to nothing
you're good enough to be the help you're
not good enough to have a stake or a
place at the table in in the department
and I think this is something that a lot
of people have unfortunately been
suckered into and they only really learn
that they were taken advantage of when
they they don't get an interview for a
position that they're you know for the
very classes that they've been teaching
for that institution they won't get
considered for a full-time position
yes
this is just like the the constant
desire for the new shinies like oh
there's there's got to be some new
up-and-coming grad student there we want
to give that position to them not like
the the guy who's been doing the work
yeah that'll that'll really stick it
when you see somebody that we call ABD
all but dissertation getting hired with
little teaching experience for the
full-time position and you stay in the
adjunct role I mean these are the sort
of things that um
over time they they wear a lot of
adjuncts down
and there's sort of a sign of contempt
um
a sign that you're being exploited
so this I think this should be viewed as
an ethical problem you know
um another thing that can happen I've
actually had this happen to me is having
the classes that you develop and teach
get poached by full-timers who are like
oh I I like that I'll do that instead so
you know you might develop a great
online class and then they're like that
looks like a cool class I'd like to
teach and now you're not teaching it
anymore
another sign that you kind of don't
matter to the department you know
and again they may teach it worse than
you as the adjunct teach it
um you also have to scramble every
semester to try to find work I I will
say
um so I don't want to talk about any
place and bad mouth them I will say that
one place that I do teach Milwaukee
Institute of Art and Design is very good
to the adjuncts and make sure that we do
have reliable work semester after
semester after semester it's not that
way in most other places where you might
not actually know whether you have a a
class until weeks before the semester
begins you know and you know it's I
think when we hear about this stuff we
should think about well what would this
be like in other Industries
you know could you get away with doing
this sort of thing like could you could
you have a company where you have
somebody doing part-time work doing good
part-time work and then you pass them
over for like you said the the kid who
comes in doesn't have any experience but
maybe has connections
would that be viewed as offensive right
most likely and you're definitely not
going to get any place that like these
places people all the time like if
you're you know
even going from flipping burgers to you
know working at some place that's
much more yes intellectually difficult
yeah um you know if they had to be there
every day then that's just not how it
usually works
um you see this a lot more in the gig
economies but those are like it's it's
only there because you've got some sort
of weird algorithm set up because
otherwise it would take way too much
time to be constantly doing this and
only because you know you you've only
got to look for if you're a department
you know you're looking to fill what 20
classes or 10 classes in your department
per semester well that depends on how
big your
um
your school is right yeah so like if if
you're thinking about a small liberal
arts college
it's gonna it will depend on the
department too so like if we're talking
about philosophy probably not that many
classes right if you're talking about
writing and writing adjuncts holy crap
do they work their butts off because you
know with philosophy we got to go in and
talk to the students and put some stuff
on the board and answer some questions
and try to get them to read some texts
and you know do some you know
exercises with them make sure they have
to do some you know tests and essays and
things like that if you're a writing
instructor you're looking at student
papers every single week and giving them
feedback on that you're spending at
least twice as much time as a philosophy
or history or you know a science
instructor would be and there are big
writing departments because every single
student has to take some writing classes
you know right
I guess
it only works in this thing because you
have these jobs that are several months
at a time you only to do that like twice
or three times a year depending on your
schedule right right
um if if any other ins or organization
did that
um for usually the amount of employees
that they're going to have that would be
real that rather impractical
I mean the the analogy that comes to
mind right away and it's not a great one
would be the seasonal kind of things
like um selling Christmas trees you know
on a Christmas tree lot or or pumpkin
farms or
um seasonal employees and department
stores I mean what else what else would
be like that yeah but the the pool of uh
employees for an adjunct position is
going to be considerably smaller than
the pool of employees for selling
Christmas trees that's right because
more skills are required right right
yeah and so like
there's one thing where you have an
abundance of you know potential hires
versus a much narrower like I've done
hiring it sucks it takes so much time it
ah you figure out who's lying to you and
who's not yeah there's all this stuff
and and to be constantly doing that
every year like of course the
administration costs are going out
they're doing like you know years worth
of uh in hiring all the time it's just
it's terrible well to be fair It's
usually the department chairs that are
stuck hiring the adjuncts rather than
like the Deans and people like that the
dean sign off at everything right the
Deans get to they say you get to hire
this number of people but it's the
department chairs who have to like reach
out and say hey are you available we
just had five sections open up can you
take three of them you know they have to
do that sort of work and and Department
chairs are usually people who've risen
from the faculty
so
you know some of them are doing it just
because they get a salary bump or a
course release
um some of them are doing it because
they're they're like motivated by the if
I'm not sure this person who's even
worse at it than me will will step in
and be the chair right so a lot of them
are not particularly into hiring people
and stuff like that
what is a course release
oh so like let's say your normal
teaching load would be
um teaching three classes per semester
so a course release means that you for
the same amount of money you only have
to teach two classes per semester
because you're compensating by doing
additional needed work like you could
actually get a course release
um to work on research projects that you
apply for or doing some other service to
the academic institution so being a
chair you know is it's a lot of work
yeah and it makes sense that they get
course releases I think
so um
do we have any other uh potential
solutions that you haven't talked about
you talked about like the unionization
thing
well I I think that a lot of the
solutions that are proposed turn out to
be impractical
you know a lot of times people be like
see and that's exactly why you need a
union
but it's really tough to put a union
into place you know in a state like
Wisconsin for example it's easier and it
would be even tougher like in a Southern
state but it's it's easier out on the um
East Coast or
um in California but it's it's not
really a solution here by the time that
adjuncts would organize and get a union
a couple years would have passed
right and if you're just going from
semester to semester that's not really
helpful
um you also you know you get a lot of
foolish advice sort of like how people
give you a foolish medical advice when
they're not doctors
um you know another thing is they'll say
well schools should stop producing so
many phds well how the hell are we going
to do that you know you're gonna like
put a choke hold on it and say each
school gets to graduate to philosophy
phds per year something who's gonna
actually make that happen there's
there's no system that would govern that
um telling them
um have you tried a side hustle like
delivering pizzas or Uber or Lyft that's
not very helpful advice because they're
already gigging right
um I actually you know there was a great
comment so I put out like a call for
comments in social media
and one that I could really relate to
um yeah so this is this is from Twitter
and it was from ashmare most people have
no clue that teaching college has become
so gigified my family thought you just
work your way up the ladder like
anything else and didn't get it
um and then another person said
something like
can't you just like go into an office
and say can you give me a full-time job
you know I'm ready to work I'm happy to
do it and my family was like that you
know when I was teaching now when I was
teaching at full time right I was
teaching at Indiana State Prison
teaching for Ball State University and
they're like you know Purdue is just
down the road from you why don't you
drive down there and go into the
philosophy Department office and talk to
the chair and see if they've got a job
for you and you'd be like that ain't how
it works man you know there's like a
whole hiring process where you gotta
like put together this massive portfolio
and then you're one of 500 applicants
and maybe you get an interview and then
you go on from there and all that and I
think a lot of people just don't don't
get it and so there there isn't any easy
solution to this I suppose the thing you
could say is
as individuals let's just be better to
people that we know are adjuncts let's
not look down on them let's not uh treat
them as if
um they deserve this you know
um
maybe take them out to lunch or
something like that I don't know what do
you have any ideas
um
I don't know make it easier for unions
well that would be something we could do
yeah I mean but then we're talking like
five ten years down the line right right
but like you know
elect people that make that easier at
least that's something yeah that
actually that could be a good good
solution not not an immediate solution
no not a term
um but yeah uh you know uh toss a coin
to your adjunct there you go yeah
um can we get like a tip jar for you
Greg
well I'm I would rather see a go to
adjuncts who need it much more than than
I do you know so maybe maybe like uh an
adjunct fund I was like whenever someone
needs like hey I've like got medical
bills yeah do that but well when you
when you see people in social media
putting out calls for that sort of stuff
Mutual Aid it's often called maybe
contribute to it so yeah but we're
almost out of time do you want to lead
us out on a final thought we leave you
with the words of Alexandra bradner the
adjunct system is immoral by any
philosophical measurement
foreign
[Music]